If you ever meet.- If you... If you ever see me in real life, (Ravi was here)
just run. ---
Run as fast., as you possibly can.
Because if you ever meet me,
you might think it will be fun..,
Exciting. Pleasant. Not in that way.
Forget about it, okay? My biggest secret...
My biggest fear that no one would ever know...
Is...
"iDubbbz Clip"
*NOOO!*
I'm just kind of awkward.
It's just gonna be painful.
It's just gonna be painful for the both of us, okay?
So it's better if you just pretend
that you didn't see me, all right?
Just..., don't make eye contact.
Do not make eye contact with me.
It's not a superiority thing,
it's just to save us both, the PAIN.
You might think, "Haha, he's exaggerating, hahahaha".
I'm so awkward.
Today we're gonna examine PewDiePie in public.
A rare specimen that isn't seen very often.
Sorry, can I borrow these?
(Guy on video): Um, but anyways, so.
The thing about PewDiePie was, he was
incredibly awkward.
I like to think of myself as kind of a, um...
(DRAMATIC SAD MUSIC)
I don't know if he was just tired or what, but,
I guess I just had this
impression by his videos that he was a
really funny, like, really crazy person in real..-
(DRAMATIC SAD MUSIC)
Oh- I can't watch this. What do you...
What do you mean, I'm awkward?
What are you talking about?
(QUICK SIP and SPIT!)
Not funny? You didn't..- I wasn't funny enough.?!
Sorry? Sorry, what?
(Guy): But he was just really mellow and chill,
which I guess is okay, but it was just kind of awkward.
And so, I got really lucky at VidCon. Everybody I-
I'm cool, okay? Like, I'm really cool.
I've always been really cool, that's the PewDiePie brand,
that everyone subscribes to! Tell 'em!
(Danny DeVito): You are a Nazi.
Why do you never fucking tell em' what I need to-
Why are you here? Why are you here?!
Alright, let's see what he said about the other people he met.
(Guy): ... Kind of like stories with an
animation in the background, and he's
super funny and..
(DRAMATIC SAD MUSIC)
Ohhhh, oh Swoozie is "super funny"!
Ohh, Swoozie's super funny, you hear that?!
(Guy): He's super big, like,
look how tiny my girlfriend and I look next to him.
I didn't realize he was such a big guy.
But yeah, Vitaly was super super cool,
I love that guy.
(DRAMATIC SAD MUSIC)
OHh VITALY IS SUPER COOL!
BUT PEWDIEPIE, EUURHGH!
EUGHUH!
No! This is... Okay, we gotta check more. I'm sure-
I'm sure, haha. I'm sure that's just a one time thing.
(Guy): How are you doing? How's it going?
(Pewds): It's good!
(Guy): Nice to meet you, man!
(Pewds): Nice to meet you. Hey!
(Guy): I can't believe it. I can't believe it, it's crazy.
(Some girl): Can I hug you?
(Pewds): Sure..?!
*laughter*
(Girl): Oh my god...
(DRAMATIC SAD MUSIC)
(THOUSAND YARD STARE)
Yeah, look how cool I look.!!
Tell them Danny. Look um
(Laughter in Background Video)
Guy: Awesome bro
Look how comfortable I am
Pewds: That's yours?
Guy: Yeah
Pewds: BigAirMedia
Guy: Media Media, Yeah.
I'm cool ok I"m
hip.. I'm down.. whatever ok i don't care.
let's look at some more public
encounters look at me here, uh doing a.. speech!
I...I do something else so I really
want to make sure that every video
I upload is entertaining! so It could take anywhere
Good one Felix, you here that he
wants every video to be entertaining
and he's doing two videos every day!!
I'm also trying to do something different
there are a lot of people doing the same thing
I try to um play games that aren't
that popular., like um sumotori dreams anyone heard of
Hey yeah what up its your boy
PewDiePie about to tell you all
about YouTube and gaming this is how you
get big you play minecraft and shit
Is there no one there? Am I just alone?!
I'm alone in there, it's no one there, who am I talking to?!
Some Guy: At home too? Stream you're own
Oh! Oh I already stream. I mean it's really simple.
Some Guy: Yeah
*(Awkward Laugh)*
Oh my God! shoot me in the head please.
Is there a gun? I always have a gun nearby.
I can't be the only one that cringes at your past self.
Alright?
Ooo Oh it's so quiet
Yeah?
Oh God oh
(AWKWARD LAUGH)
Oh my God!
(Cringe Noises)
Yeah?
Ooooh (Laughter) What the Hell?
Oh yeah I was on Swedish television once., Oh no it's when I
had 30 million viewers a month!
That's cute Felix 30 million
Alright so that was pretty much it for today
Like and favorite if you enjoyed and I'll
see you tomorrow bros Byehi!
Oh God what
is wrong with you? what is wrong with you?!
(AWKWARD LAUGH) (Groan)
DreamHack 2012 2012 the year what I
was like yeah I'll do that you want me
to go to Spain and talk about things
yeah through that God damn it you want to go
on stage and play games yeah I'll do
that that's a great idea! So basically
I just knew i was going on to Dreamhack
I didn't know I was going on stage. so,
they were like, Uh Eh just go on stage and
entertain these people all right you'll
be fine if you got to go onstage you
should have something prepared okay
I don't know who you are or what you do
just prepare fucking something I had
nothing prepared.!
Am I singing?
I'm singing...
Why would anyone watch this?
get her leia MP I was like hey maybe
it's less awkward if.. I bring someone
else on stage walking fast faces pass
them and hold down (Awkward Tune)
(Tortured) This is PAIN, this is Torture! that that
s of it at all right! live there almost
to be another Chanel whoop. It Hurts, you
don't understand how much this Pains me
I'm sweating.. I'm sweating like swimming pools.
I played happy wheels.. I played
happy wheels.. I'll.. I live- Live happy wheels!
otherwise I've enough what! oh god the
cringe! The CRINGE! (Feeling PAIN). there's more
times where I decided It was a good idea
to go outside, but the more I see it, the
more I realized it was a bad idea.
in this video I thought it'd be
funny to go outside.. to Brofist people!
(fart sound) Oh It's, that one still hurts.. that one still HURTS..!
I remember how awkward and
painful this used to be for me, compared
to this fucking video.. I think I think
it's cause there's a difference
between me and PewDiePie and unless I am
into the PewDiePie character I just
can't do certain things like it's like a
stupid stupid fucking comparison but
like.. you put on your Superman suit or
whatever all right! it's different.. so a
lot of people are like.. Oh well you say
you're awkward, but you go outside and
you do all these things like.. what, how
could you do that? It's different.. it's
different! you-you enter a character, it's
like an act I'm like an actor.
why did I wave at a fucking painting?!
what's wrong with you! well I know, I know,
who waves at a painting?!!
oh my god, every time!
what is wrong with ME?! :/ I'm not coming out
for this man., I'm not supposed to be in
this position. you don't understand.. I'm
just some fucking random Swedish nerd,
that someone happened to be the biggest
youtuber. It was never supposed to
happen the time-time went wrong some how..,
someone traveled back in time and they
fucked something up, cause I'm clearly
not supposed to be here. *feeling BAD*... oh yeah
*Feelin BAD* >_<
Oh Yah..remember then,
I was like, I can't hear you.. oh man! so
there you have, it if you ever see me..
I..you know no offense I want to meet you
but just go the other way okay just
scream Help! not good. not good. Leave a Like
if you enjoy this video. I hope it was
educational, and I hope you take it
seriously. Cause i mean every goddamn word of it.
*taking away, but I don't know what what so
my day chris thomas find you darling,
i'll be coming for your love okay. Take
me Girl...
DEAD